him with his polo fits and i honestly  thought he was joking but he said it so  seriously that i'm not sure if he is  it's called his wife that's his patch  coordinator  no you're gonna make it that's the kind  of synergy they have wonder twins  activate  ordnance leading by 17.  another rebound ball  [Applause]  jacob now has ball on him baines  [Applause]  number six for ball  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  size advantage ciaco  tapped around finally cleared by ball  terrence davis on the floor  another rebound ball number nine  that's what i'm talking about  oh that was fun you got to get out and  run  when two gets the ball off the glass  defensively he's going to find him  there it is wow that's a little flare  look at  that pass right on the money in stride  [Applause]  nothing's happening okay i'm going to  drive draw kick biz you finish it  play above